Zachary Levi is doing just that and
apparently he approves of our new show
name to thank you for putting on a shirt
today for our interview you're welcome
my quarantine has been pretty idyllic I
mean honestly like this is that on a
daily basis um I'm pretty pretty pretty
grateful for my little slice of heaven
right now live in the corn dream that's
what we're doing well besides hunkering
down at his sprawling Texas ranch so
pretty tonight the 39 year olds will
reunite with his marvelous missus Mazal
co-star Rachel Brosnahan for a night of
Covenant House Stars hey everybody it's
me dolly a slew of a-list singers will
perform live in an effort to raise kovat
19 relief funds for homeless youth
around the country so this is your
Instagram I'm playing up here you know
oh yeah honey you got dolly you guys I
got Bobby Jon Bon Jovi Joe yeah I gotta
believe somebody's called him Joe Joe
before I mean is it basically safe to
say that you and Merrill are now
co-stars I mean that's what I took you
from that means me in the street we're
gonna we're gonna figure out something
[Music]
this pandemic is sad and it's scary but
I do believe that in the in this let's
say curse that we're being handed were
being handed a lot of blessings and
speaking of pandemic this is clearly
impacted so many different productions
it up Shazaam to your release dates been
pushed to 2022
[Music]
that's still on track right now they're
writing an amazing script I don't have
any real details on that I've got some
generals and they all sound amazing you
are everyone at entertainment tonight's
man crush Monday that is I don't want to
make your head big or anything like that
I need to know the deets are you single
date and if so are you looking for love
I mean what is everybody doing other
than just you know trying to connect
with their loved ones via phones and
stuff you know it helps people in the
dating role and helps people in the
gaming world that helps people doing all
of the things I see what you're doing
there's that I see it I don't talk about
that stuff
[Music]